there's no scientific evidence out there
that something like that can really
happen it would have to be a
massive amount of fuel hey everybody i'm
meteorologist serena arnold and i've
done icing and turbulence test flights
with nasa contractors installed weather
stations on the alaska tundra and was
the director of the world famous mount
washington observatory today we're going
to be looking at storm scenes from tv
and movies and figuring out how real
they are
oh oh my god
this tornado just came and erased the
hollywood los angeles isn't free of
being hit by tornadoes they absolutely
can have them in fact since 1950 there
have been 42 recorded tornadoes in los
angeles and in 1983 south la took a
direct hit from a rather large tornado
and several people were killed the
chances of getting severe thunderstorms
can happen anywhere all 50 states of the
united states have recorded tornadoes in
them we just happened to get a few more
of them in the midwestern united states
because the ingredients for them to
happen just are there a little bit more
frequently
is anyone hurt i wouldn't be surprised
there is so much damage obviously if
you're going to be part of a media crew
you're going to want to capture a little
bit of what's going on you see the news
helicopters flying right by the tornado
which they do from time to time they'll
follow tornadoes and news helicopters
but they're not going to be very close
to it and they're zooming in i think a
little bit too
one large tornado two tornadoes merging
into one and we do see some instances
out storm chasing where you could have a
multiple vortice tornado and that means
that you actually have smaller little
tornadoes that make up a larger one and
if the condensation in there meaning the
the moisture and the water drops that
you see are visible only in those
vortices and not surrounding the whole
tornado itself it can actually make it
look like there's more than one tornado
in one specific location
[Music]
one thing that movies always kind of get
funny is the background clouds and the
surrounding storm around the tornado how
dark the sky is when there's a tornado
occurring actually depends a lot on your
position with the storm if you're going
to be on say the northeast side of the
tornado and you're going to be under the
main part of the thunderstorm it's
probably going to be really dark where
you are but there are places where you
can actually have blue sky above you
while watching a tornado tornadoes
typically occur on the southwest side of
thunderstorms and if you happen to be in
that area and say southeast of that
southwest corner of the storm you could
have beautiful weather above you and see
the sun shining on a tornado making the
storm and the tornado look white and not
dark at all it's unbelievable
yeah i'm not exactly sure what the meter
was i'm guessing it was more like a
seismograph type thing measuring the
vibrations of the earth but that
definitely wasn't an anemometer
measuring the wind speeds i'd have to
rate this one probably like a six or a
seven
i don't think a tornado would be strong
enough to pull creatures up out of the
ocean there is an instance in louisiana
in 1947 where it did rain down fish on a
small town because it was likely picked
up by a tornado it's not going to end
well for them they're going to be pulled
up to higher elevations they could
potentially freeze
which isn't going to feel well and then
they're going to be falling back down to
earth again and hitting the ground but
you're talking things that are pretty
small and pretty light
so as the remnants of hurricane ida
actually passed over new york and new
jersey just earlier this year there were
some situations where there was a flood
warning and a tornado warning happening
at the same time and a warning means
that it's imminent that it's actually
happening right now not that it's going
to if i had to rate this from one to ten
it's it's a solid
everybody one now
don't get in a car if there's a tornado
it's a terrible idea don't take safety
in your car please while we're storm
chasing we're usually out in our cars um
if you are in a safe place and you're
not too close and want to get out and
take a look at it you can but you want
to try to stay fairly far away from them
you know half mile to a mile away and
you always want to try to be
maybe you know on like the southeast
side that's usually for most tornadoes
the way they move the safest place to be
there was a really devastating situation
um with a large tornado where there were
four storm chasers killed in their
vehicle because the tornado changed
direction very rapidly it grew rapidly
its speed changed it was very
unpredictable and it ended up killing
four people who were very knowledgeable
about the weather
if you're that close to it you need to
seek shelter you should be going to a
basement if you have one if you don't
try the lowest elevation that you have
in your home and try to make it an
interior room as possible so an interior
bathroom under the stairwell any of
those places are really good safe places
in a storm
tornadoes at night are something that do
happen a lot and they're almost
impossible to see they're actually
extremely dangerous sometimes the only
way you can't see where they are is
because you're seeing flashes of
lightning reflect off the side of the
tornado or you're getting power flashes
that show you where it is seeing the
lightning right on the edges of the
tornadoes a little more rare we've had
there's been some images captured of
lightning with tornadoes happening in
close proximity but for the most part it
doesn't usually that's happening in a
different part of the storm than where
the tornado is located
so a lot of people think that it's a
pressure differential that causes
windows to break in things like that in
a storm or when there's a tornado and
it's actually not there are some
pressure differentials there and
sometimes people can feel their ears pop
if they're in a house and a tornado
passes over it but usually when you see
things break like that it's because of
debris and high wind speeds tornadoes
can pick up debris and move it and throw
it beyond the distance of where that
tornado was so you can't have cars that
end up in trees or in homes the static
interference that you see on the tv i
think is something was a lot more
popular before everything became digital
back then you know you could see some
static or some disruption in the signal
as you have a big thunderstorm
approaching may not necessarily mean
that a tornado is there but you could
definitely get some disruption of the
signals with a large severe thunderstorm
so tornadoes are pretty mysterious in
that they're a very small area of very
very high wind speeds and
weaker tornadoes or smaller ones have
wind speeds around that 100 mile an hour
or greater threshold but your very large
ef-4 ef5 tornadoes can have wind speeds
up to 300 miles an hour and that's
really really devastating because you
have such high wind speeds in a small
area they can rather pick or choose what
they choose to destroy i've seen homes
that are perfectly still and untouched
with just a roof ripped off so for it to
be able to pull off just pieces of uh
this building that they're in and take
those but leave other parts of the
building just fine isn't uncommon if i
had to rate this clip on accuracy it's
pretty good i'd give it like a seven
that's a lot of tornadoes very close
together i'd be running too if i saw
that the only way you can have multiple
tornadoes by each other like that is
sometimes when you see a tornado on the
ground it can have a satellite tornado
meaning a smaller one that's actually
part of the same storm that that is
rotating around it but that small one is
going to be tiny it's going to look more
like a like a waterspout type of a
tornado going around there but they're
really rare i've never seen one a few
meteorologists have otherwise
if you're lucky enough to see multiple
storms lined up producing tornadoes at
the same time you might be able to see
one from another but that's really a
stretch
to see them this close together and see
that many happening at one time is just
completely not possible at all the best
storm chase i've ever been on was
october 9th of 2001 in cordell oklahoma
we were out chasing and we saw seven
different tornadoes that day which was
phenomenal it was a really great chase
and we're really fortunate enough to see
seven different tornadoes including one
that was an f3 tornadoes are rated by
the fujita scale and now it's actually
the enhanced vegeta scale because it was
updated ef5 is the maximum that you can
reach on the ef scale tornadoes can
absolutely hit large metropolitan areas
like you see in this clip here a lot of
your tornadoes are a couple football
fields wide if that but there are some
big record-breaking ones out there we've
seen tornadoes up to a mile wide
and there's even been a tornado that's
2.6 miles wide across that was reported
in el reno oklahoma
a cold front can't be severe enough to
take an airplane out of the sky like
that or freeze the ocean in the way that
you saw here there was
an instance on around nantucket actually
in january of 2018 where temperatures
got cold enough where you actually could
see some slush on the top of the ocean
so if it is cold enough you can get some
ice that forms there but for it to
freeze over instantaneously like that
it's just not going to happen
cold fronts do move quickly they are
something that we can see progress
across the country at various speeds and
sometimes they can go 50 60 miles an
hour across but they just don't have
that drastic temperature change with
them i have seen some cold fronts come
across oklahoma where the back side of
the cold front it was in the teens and
on the front side it was just close to
70 degrees that's a really substantial
and record-breaking cold front but to
see things you know happen like you saw
here in this clip where people are
freezing or water's freezing instantly
it's just not possible for that to
happen to be that extreme just isn't
possible it'd have to get like a two
from me cold fronts are real and they do
exist they're not this extreme and uh
there was a tornado but it was just a
few too many of them
the way this tornado does the damage to
this farm and to that building is
actually pretty accurate
having a tornado that far away actually
pulls someone up into it isn't realistic
very few people have ever been able to
say they've seen the inside of a tornado
i don't know of anybody personally who's
been pulled up into a tornado inside
their car and has lived to tell about it
there have been a lot of people who have
taken some glancing blows from tornadoes
or have been spun around on the ground
in their car while the tornado passes
over but no instances of someone being
pulled up in their car into the tornado
and then coming out the top of the storm
there's no scientific evidence out there
that something like that can really
happen it would have to be a
massive amount of fuel you do see
tornadoes that are made up of fire
though actually a lot of times when
there are forest fires you get things
called fire whirls which are like a dust
devil and they can encompass flames and
actually be caused by the fire itself so
that's the closest thing i could think
of to what you saw here they looked a
little bit more realistic than when you
see in some other movies but coming out
up the top of the tornado and stuff like
that it's a little bit of a stretch i'd
give it like a five
was he hanging on by his tongue yeah i
believe so okay you can take your weight
in pounds
cut that in half and that'll be the
speed in miles per hour that you'll be
able to walk around max without getting
blown over so if you weigh 150 pounds
it's going to be about 75 mile an hour
winds are going to be the max that
you're going to stay standing for
they're showing people being pulled up
and sucked up so typically if you think
about say a skydiver falling out of an
airplane and they're free falling they
reach what's called terminal velocity
that's around 120 to 125 miles an hour
so in order to pick somebody up again
and do that and be taking them the wind
speeds would have to be at least 120 to
125 miles an hour and how quickly they'd
be moving past that would have to be
added on to that amount so if you want
to see someone fly away from you at 25
miles an hour you're going to need about
150 mile an hour winds to do so
lightning is really dangerous you know
it can actually occur
30 miles outside of a storm so where you
have your storm happening lightning can
go beyond it so that's why there's a lot
of these rules like the 30 30 safety
rule so after you see the last flash of
lightning
wait 30 seconds until you hear that
thunder so then you know that that's at
least six miles away then wait another
30 minutes before you go outside and
this is really critical for weather
safety to make sure you don't get hit by
lightning because thousands of people
are hit by lightning every year i mean
it's it's got to be a one i don't know
anyone who's got the power of weather
and i also don't know anyone who can
hold on in 120 mile an hour winds with
their tongue
see if i can get the weather
there were a lot of cues in that to go
somewhere safe and not just be messing
around on the staircase there were
sirens going off there was a loss of
power there was the tornado warning on
the television all things that people
need to pay attention to and those are
all serious you need to go take shelter
when those things are happening
so the sirens you hear in the background
are common in areas that are tornado
prone so if there's areas that are
likely to get tornadoes in the midwest a
lot of towns have tornado sirens now the
average for the national weather service
is somewhere between 8 and 11 minutes of
warning before the tornado occurs
letting you know that it's on its way
the way they showed the inside of the
house moving you know you could see some
vibrations and things like that
happening during a tornado
if it's passing by it could last for a
fairly long period of time like they
showed here i'd give it about a seven i
don't see too much wrong with it
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video why not check out the
one right above